[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
new information released on the closed
hearing of the so-called doomsday cult
couple
what defense attorneys for lori valo and
chad dabal told the judge
and not the public plus potential jury
members are already being contacted
in the trial of the former officers
accused of murdering george floyd
the questions prosecutors and defense
want to know now months ahead of the
trial
a fire cocon 19 scientists fires back
after agents raid her home
while she's calling their search warrant
a sham and the family of a texas man
killed by police are outraged by an
officer's actions
what the newly released body cam video
shows this shooting was
unnecessary and constitutional
and unjustifiable
on crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer
along with terry austin new information
in the case of the doomsday cult mom
lori valo but first the jury
questionnaire is out in the george floyd
case
and we have it here potential jury
members in minnesota are already being
asked questions for the upcoming trial
of the four former police officers
questions like list all details you know
about the victim and defendants
have you watched the video of george
floyd's death and if so how many times
did you participate in demonstrations
against police brutality
did you or someone you know get injured
or suffer property damage
during the protests part two of the
questions focus on media habits
including what is your primary source of
news how often do you see news updates
on social media
part three is about police contacts have
you ever personally seen the police use
more force than was needed have you ever
been restrained or put in a chokehold by
law enforcement
then the potential jurors asked to rate
their opinions in a lengthy list
about how they feel towards the media
discrimination and trusting police the
16-page questionnaire
was mailed to citizens in hennepin
county the trial expected to last three
weeks
jury members will be sequestered during
deliberations
jury selection is scheduled to start on
march 8 and could take three weeks
the trial is scheduled to start on march
29th and could take another three weeks
the judge is expected to decide at a
hearing next month whether to grant the
defense's request
to delay it until july joining me now is
criminal defense attorney nicole debord
and terry austin nicole as a defense
attorney
some questions i feel have to be asked
in person so you can see that person's
body language as they respond how do you
see jury selection working
in this type of format well i think this
is really just a start
this case is obviously so emotionally
charged and
is so public that the lawyers and the
court really need a head start
in terms of finding out who has already
formed a very
solid opinion about what should happen
in this case yeah and this could
probably really
weed out people to begin with like
nicole is talking about no terry
do you see this as the future for jury
selection or just
necessary for the times considering
we're during covet 19
you know i think it makes a lot of sense
to have these questionnaires filled out
from a distance i mean yes you're right
it's wonderful to be able to see
how a prospective juror responds to the
question you want to look at
whether or not they're telling the truth
their body language but
it is helpful to have them sit and
ponder these questions maybe answer them
more thoroughly so i think this is going
to be around for a while
partially for covet but i think it's
going to stay around because it might
make some sense
yeah and of course i think nicole you're
kind of hinting at as well police car
come wrong
but it seems like this might just help
weed out those people who are
really not meant for this trial off the
jump and maybe maybe make it easier for
that three-week
jury selection that's coming up uh next
year
thank you guys for your input i think
that's exactly right i mean this is
going to be a huge
challenge to get a group of jurors to
consider the facts of this case
who don't already have a very strong
opinion about what they think should
happen without knowing the facts
and so they're trying to find out who
those people are to make sure that
the ones that they do pick have a fresh
start and
have a clean slate absolutely and now to
another of our top stories
terry has the latest on the lorry vallo
day bell case
brian the judge overseeing the case has
just unsealed records of a closed door
hearing
and we're learning a lot of new
information valo and her husband chad
dabel
are charged with concealing evidence
related to the deaths
of valo's two children the bodies of
seven-year-old joshua jj vallo
and sixteen-year-old tylie ryan were
found on daebel's property
defense attorneys for the so-called
doomsday cult couple
accuse prosecutor rob wood of witness
intimidation
and want him removed from the case it
relates to a call
wood had with balo's sister and
sister-in-law
woods says he did nothing wrong and
wants an expedited hearing
to clear it up the couple is due back in
court on january 6.
brian terry january 6 seems to be a big
day
arguments on whether wood should be
removed from the case and whether there
should be a change of venue
any thoughts on how those arguments may
play out
i think that wood is not going to be
removed from the case you know first of
all he said this
that the attorney was there doing the
interview he was just speaking
preliminarily and the investigation was
done by investigators and not him
you know so i think the judge is going
to rule in his favor and keep him
on the case because i don't think he
interfered you know as to venue
there is probably no other county in the
state
where someone has not heard of this case
so i think the venue will not be changed
either
thanks now nicole the beginning of this
saga the cases are pretty intertwined in
the defense's arguments
they seem to be splitting apart a little
do you think that's foreshadowing of
what's to come in the trial
i think that's a great point really when
things get tough sometimes what you see
are the defense teams that had
previously been unified starting to
separate and pick their own path
and you know certainly that can create a
very damaging scenario for one of the
defendants and i
and i have no doubt that both of these
accused will do what they can to improve
their own personal situation
yeah especially when the bodies of these
two young children are
found on chad dabo's property i can't
imagine that laurie vallo is going to
stick by his side
too long from a legal standpoint but of
course we'll keep eyes on that
still ahead on law and crime daily the
latest on singer r kelly's criminal
prosecution
and when his many trials are scheduled
to begin but first
florida data scientist is suing the
state why she's calling a search warrant
on her home a quote
sham after the break
[Music]
the now fired florida data scientist is
suing the state after agents executed a
search warrant on her home
rebecca jones is accusing authorities of
terrorizing her family earlier this
month
in retaliation for not falsifying data
jones was terminated from her position
working on the coven 19 dashboard
at the florida department of health the
warrant reportedly was in response to a
complaint of an unauthorized user
sending a message to employees urging
them to quote
speak up before never 17 000 people are
dead
jones posted the videos of the raid
inside her home to her twitter account
come outside outside who else is in the
house man my two children
and my husband where's your husband calm
down you want the children now
call them all mr jones come down the
stairs
now
police come down now
after jones posted her video the florida
department of law enforcement released
body cam video of the warrant
what's in the door now
open it now
come outside who else is in the house
man my two children
and my husband is your husband calm down
you want the children now
we'll call them all down there is no
need for this
at all i'm to explain everything to you
about why we're here
but right now we're off to a pretty
rocky start all you had to do was answer
the door there was no doubt who we were
veteran swap member and crime analyst
lisa lockwood reviewed both of the
videos at the request of the law and
crime network
when you gather intel for a search
warrant you realize that there will be
children on the scene and you take
the necessary precautions for that and
you could hear her scream out they're
pointing a gun at my child and that
wasn't the case
the officer came to the door and when
you ascend a staircase and go around a
staircase you have to look up the
staircase
and make sure nobody's up there and you
have your your gun drawn in a particular
way
in order to look at the threat and there
were no children at the top of the
stairs
and one of the things that rebecca
alleges later on in a counter suit is a
battery because
it's it's job of the police to make sure
that you don't have a weapon so they did
search her
and when you have a male police officer
doing the actual search they can only go
so far
they touched her ribs and they touched
her sides and
doing that to look for a weapon i don't
believe is enough to warrant a battery
against the police officer
back with me for legal analysis is
nicole debord and terry austin nicole
when you look at these videos are you
seeing any legal issues or
just an angry citizen whose home was
raided
i'm seeing an angry citizen whose home
was raided you know the police officer's
job is not to evaluate whether or not
the warrant that they were given by a
judge is based on correct legal
information it's to go through the
correct procedures and execute that
warrant and i didn't see anything
outside of what we would expect to see
in the service of a warrant
on either of these videos agreed it
seemed pretty um
common based on the videos that i've
seen from my own clients here in
brooklyn
terry jones is arguing which i think is
true that an ip address can be faked
is that something officers should be
checking before executing warrants or
not
i don't think they have to necessarily
check that because i don't think it's
their responsibility but i do think they
should know
that the ip address could be fake and so
in my opinion i think that you know i'm
not very
tech savvy and i know that i just think
that the response was a little bit
extreme i don't think they should have
come in with
guns this was an email she didn't
threaten to
you know blow up the uh company
and the email could have come from other
people so i just sort of think that the
response
was a little bit extreme i don't think
jones really has
a real case against the police but i do
think that
what they did there was more than they
should have done in a situation where
you know there's an email like this yeah
often times when i look at body worn
cameras these types of
search warrants and arrest warrants they
draw their guns because
the person they're going to look at
either has guns or drugs or a history of
violence
this isn't the case so while they might
not have broken any rules
it's kind of peculiar to draw guns in
this type of situation but we'll talk
about it more later
coming up on law and crime daily the
family of a man killed by police
officers react
to body cam video of the shooting plus
bill cosby reveals he's refusing to
shower in prison
and barely leaves his cell why the
convicted comedian says he's remaining
hopeful
[Music]
next
[Music]
a federal judge has set a new date for r
b singer r
kelly r kelly is now expected to go to
trial on september 13th of 2021
for federal child pornography and sex
crime charges in chicago
two previous trial dates have been
pushed back due to the coronavirus
pandemic
prosecutors say the singer filled
himself having sex with
underage girls he's also facing charges
in illinois and minnesota
as well as federal charges in new york
the new york trial is scheduled
for april of 2021.
sex offender former actor and comedian
bill cosby says he's very hopeful his
conviction will be overturned
in an exclusive interview with the daily
mail cosby revealed he stopped showering
in prison
after a coveted outbreak and spends 20
hours a day in lockdown
khasi was found guilty of sexually
assaulting andrea constand
in 2018. he was sentenced to three to
ten years
and could be released as early as
september 2021.
the pennsylvania state supreme court
heard arguments earlier this month
on why his defense believes he deserves
a new trial
attorney gloria allred represents 33
accusers three of which testified
against cosby at his second trial
she told me she's confident her client's
testimony will be affirmed
he has consistently said he feels no
remorse
he's not essentially taking any
responsibility because he says he's
innocent of
what he was convicted of three counts of
aggravated
indecent sexual assault so whether
if he's showing no remorse uh whether
the parole board will in fact grant him
parole
i don't know i think my clients just
want justice to be done so we'll have to
see
what form justice takes if any
now nicole we watch the hearing do you
see any reasons
for cosby to be hopeful in his appeal
you know the best time to win your case
is at the trial court level by the time
you're arguing these finer points at the
appellate level
the hope has dwindled and certainly it's
his last hope so i can understand why
he's hanging on to it
but i think it's a difficult hurdle to
cross for him
all right we'll definitely keep eyes on
that terry i keep going back to cosby's
defense attorney saying
five uncharged witnesses testifying was
prejudicial and she knows that because
in the first trial
he wasn't he was not convicted could you
see him being hopeful or do you agree
with nicole
not much reason to be hopeful here well
i agree with both of them i think that
you know he probably will not win
but on the other hand you know the
argument went well for him and it sounds
like
the judges are kind of leaning towards
not
uh you know listening to the argument
that it wasn't prejudicial i think
having five
witnesses who testified might have been
prejudicial and
they looked at the fact that the trial
court judge only allowed
the one witness in the first trial and
five in the second trial
and you know in pennsylvania they're
going to only being
allowing these witnesses if in fact they
can
demonstrate a signature pattern of abuse
and
i'm not certain all five of them fit the
same pattern so
we'll see what happens but i think that
if he has any hope of winning on appeal
it's on this very issue
quickly nicole i see you kind of nodding
your head agree or disagree with what
terry said
totally agree with terry this is this is
a strong issue and it's
his strongest hope for sure yeah i mean
he doesn't have
many um shots to make here but i think
this one is probably the only one that
may
not saying it will but we'll make it
thank you nicole and terry when we come
back
newly released body cam video shows the
moments after a fatal officer-involved
shooting
in texas but what happened before our
expert analysis
after the break
[Music]
the family of a texas man killed by a
police officer says
the shooting looked more like quote a
drive-by than a legal pursuit
22-year-old joshua feast was killed on
december 9.
according to the lamarck police
department fees had two outstanding
felony warrants
officer jose santos was reportedly
monitoring fees home
for an investigation into recent
drive-by shootings officials released
the officer's body cam to the public
it shows santos in his car and fees
exiting the passenger
side of the vehicle santos says he saw a
feast turn towards him holding a gun
so he fired one round investigators
report feast was positioned with his
backside towards the officer
at the time he was shot the first 30
seconds of the video that capture the
shooting are silent
due to a manufacturing setting the audio
begins as soon as the officer hits
record
[Music]
41 we're in front of 10 10 pearl
first unit to get here i need you to
recover the gun he dropped it just
outside of
dodge charger
stay on the ground do not move
he pulled out a gun he got a couple
felony warrants he pulled a gun on me
when i get supervisor here i'm gonna
need y'all to determine
if we need to bring the medics in or
carry him out
[Laughter]
all right let's put him in cuffs feast
mothers says the body cam video is
disturbing and is calling for an outside
investigation
into the officer's actions
this is the hardest thing i ever went
through
and it hurt me to see that officer
santos let my son
bleed out on the ground after he begged
for help
he kept asking for help and then after
he took his last breath
he was even handcuffed handcuffed
so like i said it's the hardest thing
that i have ever experienced
my grandkids alia and josh jr they don't
understand that their father is not
coming back
even if you say he's gone they still
think he's coming back
attorney benjamin crump represents the
family and is calling for the officer's
dash cam video to be made public
the sheriff gave an interview on cbs
and in that interview he told
the reporter that his investigators said
the body camera video
showed joshua feast coming
in the direction of officer jose
santos and pointing a gun at him
nothing that the investigators told the
sheriff
that would be exhibited on that video
was there so the question is
why would they lie when you watch that
video
it's more like a drive-by shooting
instead of a legal pursuit
of a suspect
terry we've been here before we look at
the video we hear the claims
they don't seem to mesh very well what
should we be focusing on here to get to
the truth
the video you know based on the video
footage there
i don't think that there was reasonable
force here
i mean deadly force is only supposed to
be used by
a police officer if they reasonably
believe
that the subject poses you know a
significant threat of serious bodily
injury
or death to themselves or others and
here clearly
we saw that joshua was running away he
wasn't running towards we did not see
him
pulling a gun and so clearly this isn't
a case of where
the police officer thought he was
threatened and i am
really concerned by the fact that they
did not offer any sort of
medical assistance and that they put him
in handcuffs
clearly he was bleeding out there they
didn't need to use the handcuffs this
needs to be investigated
good eye on that not calling medical
support right away nicole this happened
about 40 miles from where you are in
houston how is your texas community
reacting and what do you think the next
steps are going to be
in this case i think the next steps are
going to be a very thorough
investigation and it's very possible
that
more than one agency will be involved in
the investigation
um the video does raise some difficult
points it's an ex
it's a it's a difficult video to watch
and
i think it's going to be important to
know whether or not there was even a
weapon
found uh was there anyone who captured
any kind of video that even demonstrates
that any part of the officer's statement
was correct i think we have a lot more
information that we're going to be
receiving over time as this
investigation goes on
absolutely i mean we've been here before
you've got a statement by the officer
you've got body worn camera thank god
we've got that so we can compare and
contrast and see what
actually happened but if it is as we
have seen that this individual that he
is running away and shot in the
back without a gun being pulled out
we'll see how that plays as it goes on
thank you nicole and terry for joining
us and thank you for joining us here at
law on crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you